last talk of this morning we have Miguel
Sanchez alone Peggy he will talk about
Python for developing the real-time
automated trading platform so about
making money yes a lot of money buying
so hi everybody and welcome to this
presentation it's sorry sorry yeah and
applause so how everybody and welcome to
this presentation on Python for
developing an automated trading platform
for real-time operation I'm really
excited to be here so I'd like to take
this opportunity to thank open systems
which is the company I've been working
with in this project in particular
Fernando for the last two years for
allowing me to come here today and talk
about this project so I hope you join
first of all a little bit about us as i
said this print has been developed in
open sistemas and in particular in the
research and development department
which is led by Fernando malarkey who is
among the audience today I don't know
where he's sitting right now okay okay
right there hi Olivia about me as well
my name is miguel sanchez de Leon Peggy
I'm an industrial engineer with
background in electronics automatic
control and computer science and I feel
I feel passion for programming and data
analysis statistics and machine learning
I started programming with Python about
two years ago zactly when I started
working with open systems and since then
I've been gradually falling in love with
this programming language which I
currently using a daily basis so what's
the motivation behind this project if
you go on the internet and search for
currently available platforms for
automated trading you may find things
like TradeStation metatrader a ninja
trader and in fact a lot of other tools
each of them with their own little
differences however they are they all
share some caveats so for example they
are proprietary and they are very
heavily dekstop oriented so many of them
cannot even run if you don't have a
desktop environment and do it provide
Linux support right I think you guessed
it right most of them know
even many of them do not provide
non-windows support and the most
important thing can use Python to create
my strategies and the answer here is a
big no so what we wanted we wanted to
have control over our own tool so we
needed to be able to modify it at will
so we needed the source code we wanted
it to have an optional graphical user
interface on mandatory and we wanted it
to be multi platform so that we could
run it on different operating systems or
at least in major operating systems and
of course we wanted it to be programmed
in Python so is this possible that's the
question and the answer is yes we'll see
how so allow me to introduce you to
always markets or markets it's a broker
independent platform for real-time a
traumatic trading broken independent
means that it should be able to run with
any broker available out there as long
as the broker provides you with a
convenient API to interact with it is
implemented over always brain will see
later what OS brain is but for now I
think it is sufficient to to note that
OS rain is what is called a multi-agent
system in which you have different
agents or actors which are running
independently and which communicate with
each other using message passing it is
designed for real-time automated trading
that makes it it must be fast which days
and it also it must be robust so you
must be able to implement rival ability
agents if you want to and also if an
agent at support at some point crashes
you want the system to keep on working
you don't want to affect the rest of the
system so that you can recover that
agent and all the system will still keep
working so here's another view of an
example of an always market a creature
as we can see the input of this system
is just the market data row market data
and in the output we will have the
market orders such as for example buy or
sell so this little cell person there
are the actual agents or actors and the
arrows begin between them represent the
message passing for communication inside
the circles you can see some names which
are the roles that the agents are
playing these agents are specialized
okay in some role so let's start with
one on the left which is called the
feeder
the feeder is an agent whose only
purpose is to get market data from the
broker that means that this agency in
particular must be broker depend on okay
we must create a different agent a
different feeder for each broker and it
is a good example of a multi-threaded
agent will see later what that means but
for now I think it's sufficient to
understand that Peter usually needs to
deal at least with with a stream of
real-time market data and then perhaps
another threat for handling requests
from system like for example get the
most recent history of this symbol so
going back to the overview we have just
on the right of fear an agent Cole ruder
this agent aims to be a broker
independent provider so it's an injured
that act for providing as the rest of
the system with market data but it is
brokering dependent so it's only purpose
is to store and distribute this market
data the market data that comes from the
feeders and it is also able of course to
update market history that he has in his
own memory with real-time updates that
come from the feeder and it is also able
to resemble market data so it for
example ruder has a one minute period
based market data history and then an
agent asks for two-minute period data it
may be able if it has sufficient history
to resample the data and created
automatically so market data can be
divided maybe in three main kinds one of
them is called the tick which is just
the ask and bid prices at a given time
stamp the other one is the bar which is
basically the open high low and close
values of the price during a time stamp
okay during a period and a bar series
which is simply a serious bars sorted by
a timestamp so they are all implemented
as numpy arrays and as you may have
noticed the bar series in a real time
system like this one are continuously
changing so we're not using okay we're
not using directly and Nampa array but
rather a view so we have a base rail
what we call a buffer in which we make
the updates with new bars calm
then later we just update the view of it
for it to grow or to move and this way
we avoid having to perform full memory
copies on each a day so it is a little
bit more efficient going back to the
overview just on the right of ruder
we've got the brains the brain is the
most common agent in the system okay it
is able to subscribe to Rueter for
example to receive market data and it's
also able to subscribe to other brains
so that it can receive also the
processed data from other brains in the
network it's the agent that runs the
actual algorithm so the strategies for
investing and therefore it needs to be
able to send orders like buy or sell at
a given time we're not going to talk
about today about the algorithms that
we've developed of course but it's
important to note that as this system is
written in Python and also the agent is
written in Python our strategies are
written in Python so we can make use of
the great ago system available out there
in Python for data analysis and machine
learning so you can use pandas ticket
learn hi-pi number piano whatever you
want so really you can do anything that
you can do with Python which is anything
so it's great now one of the best things
of this architecture is that you can
implement some kind of abstraction of
the market concept so if you implement a
hierarchy with those brains in the
lowest abstraction level in the lower
layer you have those brains which work
died early withdrawal market data and
then as we go up in the layer will start
getting concept which are more abstract
and which are more close to how a human
trader works so for example we could be
able to talk about a market structure or
detecting some kind of patterns or
market intention so this is really
useful and the last agent that we have
here in the overview is the one on the
right which is called the trader this
agent is very simple it's very similar
to the feeder in the sense that it is
also broker dependent of course and it's
only purpose is to handle orders that
comes from the system okay from the
brains it is also an example of a
multivariate agent so just to make it
clear we could imagine this
in which the brain in blue was not
present before and then at some point we
spun it there and then this brain might
subscribe to some data in bruder ruder
made no have that data babe also it may
send a message to theatre fee they will
take care of getting that data from the
from the provider from the broker and
then send it back to Rooter I'm from
loser back to the brain all in a
completely synchronous way so at some
point this brain will have some perhaps
historical data and will start receiving
real-time updates from Rueter so this
means that this brain is probably going
to send orders to the trader based on it
on the algorithm on the strategy and it
may also start publishing information
that all the brains in the network may
start to use in order to make their
decisions there are other agents that we
have mentioned such as the logger which
simply locks messages from other engines
an informer which may be used to publish
information about the accounts balanced
or the rate at which we can trade out
our accounts currency with other
currencies and the over mine which is
kind of a console or terminal that we
can use to handle brains in the system
so we can kill some or modify others or
some new ones all this of course while
the system is still running apart from
this tool we have also developed a
graphical user interface so this
graphical user interface is used to
visualize market data in real time it's
also used to visualize with indicators
what's an indicator indicator is just
like a mathematical transformation of
the raw market data that helps us
interpret the market and it is
integrated with always markets will see
later that in fact this graphical user
interface is nothing more than another
agent in the system so how we do is we
used QT or cute however you want to call
it because of its great portability and
because it's probably the most values
out there but it's more important it's
piechota graph which is a much less
known module in python which is written
pure python and it's a library for fast
performant real-time display it justice
is back in cuties graphics view or it
can use also a GL back in so one of the
best things that this tool has is that
implements already all the user
interface or the user interaction that
you can imagine so there's already
zooming in or something out in one axis
or two axes and panning everything you
want in real time it works out as box so
it's just perfect let's see how it looks
like so this is the main window and the
right we can see the brains that are
present in the system we can help them
and of course we can create new tabs or
new windows each of them with a separate
chart okay they are all independent we
can be sized different data in each of
them of course each of one each of those
charts represents a different agent in
the system so charges are well as are as
well independent now let's see how the
chart looks like from the chart we are
able to change the market data that we
are visualizing so in this case we're
just changing the period and we see that
it is displayed at monthly when we
change that information what we are
doing is just sending a message to rotor
okay remember this is just an agent and
we've got a boot and a button there so
we can stop the automatic view update as
you see we can zoom in or zoom out and
pan and everything is done directly with
package' graph okay we haven't done
anything there and last but not least
there's the indicators menu which you
can access on the top right which gives
you a list of indicators that you can
add to the chart as you can see you can
add new indicators in new pots just
below the market data but as well you
can of course plot indicators over the
market data so for example we can add a
simple mobile average spring and we are
able to modify the parameters these
indicators in real time so we can modify
the one that we just started change the
period and it will be updated in the
child of course everything else like the
zoom in and zoom out works still
suspected right needless to say that you
can of course remove indicators that you
added previously to the plot
so let's continue now as I said this is
very important a key concept each chart
it's an agent okay it's completely
separated and in fact when we change the
market data that we are visualizing we
just subscribing to a new feet from
ruler and when we add an indicator what
we are doing is not calculating the
indicator output in the India graphical
interface we are rather spawning a new
agent a new brain that is doing the
calculations for us and we are just
subscribing to updates to that brain so
at the end all the calculations are
performed within always markets not in
the graphical user interface so we've
said how we have implemented our
graphical user interface which was very
simple just import patio de Graaff and
everything was on but we haven't
explained how we have implemented always
markets and OS market has implemented
has been implemented over what we have
called OS brain I was brain is a
general-purpose multi-agent system as we
mentioned before a general purpose but
in a multi-agent system is one in which
the agents are independent from each
other and which communicate using
measured patch in passing apart from
that OS market has ways for implementing
complex systems with easy configuration
and deployment process with later how so
when I say it is a general-purpose
multi-agent system what do I really mean
what I mean that of course this is not
only meant to be used within always
markets so we for example use this for
portfolio analysis and optimization
we've got a setback test millions of
actives and then we've got a pool of
distributed workers in different
machines and then we send a small random
sample groups of back tests to those
workers and they perform the
computations that you calculate the ship
ratio this drawdown and the magics
correlation fold the back test and then
end up with what we call a mini
portfolio so this is really simply like
a filter so after these computations are
performed we've got a set a smaller set
of back tests so what we do is we repeat
this process in multiple layers like in
the higher
our key until we reach a final portfolio
find out big portfolio this is of course
not the perfect portfolio but it is a
very good one and of course it is
computationally acceptable okay at least
we can calculate it so we also say that
in this system agents are independent so
the question is are there other
processes are the threat wear if you
wear at James workshop on Friday your
you already know what the deal is and if
you don't better for you your life is
much better so the decision here was
very simple as the most widely used
implementations of Python which are
probably see Python and pie pie both
implement the deal we had to you to use
processes in order to avoid hitting
performance issues we also say that in
the system agents communicate using
message passing so how do they do that
they do that with serum q and why
because it is so cool that if you don't
have a project that needs it you should
make one that's the main reason but
apart from that of course there are
others so for example it provides us
with higher-level sockets than bro
sockets we don't have to we had create
that annoying buffer and start receiving
parts of a message which I've received
the full message it is also completely a
synchronous communication and one of the
most amazing things about Purim view is
that it allows you to connect from a
client to a to another server that it is
not already be ended it is not being the
dead it also implements a multi pattern
with about patterns that are commonly
used such as the request reply pattern
publisher subscriber pull pull pull push
etc you can change the transport
protocol also if you want to optimize
communications between threads or
between processes or between machines
and also you can use multi casting if
that's what you need it's also
multi-language because it is a library
implemented in C++ C C++ so you have
already a lot of buildings for your
favorite language so you don't have no
excuse it is apart from that
multi-platform are scalable so yeah it
is not a bad piece of somewhere now for
what we know now we can
have an idea what a basic agent is we
know that it is a system process we know
that in it implements method for ECB
near and connecting because that's what
we want we want them to connect to other
agents in the system and we can beam and
connect using different patterns with
different communication patterns from
serum cubes or requested by publishing
subscriber etc normal agent activates on
incoming messages so usually the agent
is just pulling for all input socket and
waiting for a new message to arrive in
order to start processing okay in order
to activate itself and multi-threading
may be used within the agent we know
that it is a process but we can use
multi theory and still avoid concurrency
because we can communicate those threads
using 0m view as well and using what is
called an improv in process socket so we
also said that it was very easy to
configure and deploy this system and how
is that is it true but we know that
agents are independent but however we
need them to know the addresses of other
agents in order to connect to them so
should we make for example a
configuration file that's not the
solution because there may be many
circuits there are many agents many
circuits so we don't want to do that
that's very tedious and in fact for most
agents you are not really interested in
fixing the address you you just don't
care if you could just assign a random
address that would be much simpler much
convenient so if only we could I do not
just an ID I have something like a name
server at least to refer to the agents
with an alias a simple way to access
those agents or if only we kids have
something like an over mind some entity
that was able to configure the salience
and for example say you been to this
address and then get this address
remotely and then use it to connect
other agent to the one that bended
before so is this possible and then
here's where pyrophoric comes in pyrus
another great piece of software piracy
pirate python remote object and allows
has to treat remote objects as local so
what pyro is doing is to start a server
and the server
we used to serve a Python object in the
remote machine orange and remote process
and then it provides us with what with
what it's call a proxy I practice a
local object that we can use to access
attributes of the remote object and we
can use to call methods of the remote
object so we treated just as if we were
handling or working with the remote
object that in fact all the calls are
serialized with pie with pyro and go to
the remote server and get executed there
and we got the rest'll back in our
machine and apart from that it already
has a name server implementation so it's
a win-win decision now we can understand
better what a real agent is a real
engine is a still a system process that
hasn't changed but this system runs a
pyro multiplexed server it's runs a
server who is serving the actual agent
object so the agent that we defined
before who can bend and connect to other
agents in a very easy way and basically
with karim what is called main thread
that is running in this in this process
the main loop the main loop that as we
mentioned before is simply pulling for
incoming messages so as a conclusion we
were able to implement with Python a
general-purpose multi-agent system and
we made those agent independent using
processes and we implemented message
passing using zeromq and how about the
configuration well we've seen that with
pyro is very easy to deploy and
configure complex systems so let's have
a look at some code samples here let's
jump to the second sample here so mmm
this is a very simple example we've got
two agents one of them is what we have
called a pusher and you wanna pull er
those are the aliases and we are simply
sending a message from the butcher which
is a hello world and then from the bush
from the cooler we're just receiving the
message and print it out so the first
line in here is where we launched the
name server
so we run we launched a random name
server we don't care about the address
what it is launched and then we create a
pusher with this function run agent so
this function what is doing it's
creating a new process it's a completely
separate process and one we what we get
in return is the proxy the proxy to the
remote object to the remote agent that
is running ok I'm the same way the
puller we are just getting another proxy
to access that remote object which is
which is running in another in another
process so it is a remote object and
then here what we do is we execute
through the birth through this proxy a
method a remote method which is in this
case the beaming and we wanted to create
bending that use the serum q pattern
push so as you can see we're not
specifying the address we just want it
to be into our random address and we get
that address in return so even if it's a
remote call pyro is serializing the
address back to us so that we can have
it in our configuration script so we can
use it later to connect the puller to
this address this is also when we say
pullard connect this salsa remote call
okay and we can have a look here at the
implementation of the functions so for
example up as we can see here we are
configuring the remote agent the pusher
in order to change its behavior is
something that we can do as well what we
are doing here is we are changing the
method ido method arrow in an agent
normally does nothing by default and
what we are doing is we're telling the
remote agent to use this function that
we defined there which will lock an
information message saying just send in
a message and then winds will send
actually a measure to hell world message
so we are serialized in this faction
that we have defined in here and the
remote object is modifying its behavior
in order to use it and then when we
connect the puller in here the last line
we give a first parameter the address
and then we pass
parameter which is the handler which is
implemented here so we also define the
handler in this in this file and we tell
the agent that when it receives a
message it should just unlock an
informational log message saying
received and then the message that is
received this is just the same example
as before but in this case instead of
configuring all the system using proxies
we might want to do the configuration
using subclassing inheritance so what
we're doing this with just reading a new
class based on base agent class and then
we tell this asian on initialization
first of all beans so create a new push
circuit and then on middle what should
we do when we are either when we don't
receive input message just lock the
information message sending a message
and send a hello world message so the
only difference is that here after we
created named the random server when we
execute function run agent we are
passing a new parameter base so we are
just telling the remote process to
create an instance of this new class
okay so we are free to use either
subclassing if we feel comfortable with
object-oriented programming or we're
free to use also the proxies and as a
last example we're going to see here and
always market the sample not a novice
brain so in this case we r sub classing
brain and we are just implementing one
method this is a stupid sample then use
it of course in real life and we are
implementing an algorithm in here in
which if the clothes value with the
clothes price at this moment is higher
than the clothes price price before
we're going to buy otherwise we're going
to sell very stupid also very simple as
we can see there's a call here send
order which as you already know will
send a message to the trailer and the
trailer will take care of executing this
order against the broker so down here
how do we start no its market
architecture well in this case we're
using an architecture that is made to
interact with onda which is one of the
brokers available out there and then
we're telling the system to start
streaming some euro dollar information
market information and here's word
mannix where the magic is we're
executing this method which is a drain
and we give the brand name we tell also
the system to use this new class that we
created above to create this agent and
then we can access the proxy to this
agent to this brain simply like it if
the system was a dictionary it's just a
get Edom implementation so we for
example can change the attributes of the
remote brain we can set the back
attributed to and the last line is the
most important line we are telling the
brain to subscribe to router so that you
can start receiving data of your dollar
one mins with a one min speriod and so
as a final completion we were able to
implement a fully functional real-time
automated trading platform just using
Python and I think that in a very
convenient way so Python have to improve
to be a great language for this
particular problem so that was so if you
want to find some references they are
here in the presentation it is not all
uploaded to get happen it will be
probably a Monday and if you want to
find the content information so that you
can send us an email to Fernando or to
me or if you want in case you want to
have a look at our website our blog or
in case you want to follow us on Twitter
so that's it thank you very much for
your attention and if you have any
questions come say yes
questions I think further they talk I'm
interested how does it compare to when
dopey amigos and top Ian looks to be
doing kind of similar similar things not
exactly the same but in Python also yes
cuanto p and if i'm not mistaken okay
because it's been a while since the last
time I have a look at it it gives you an
implementation so that you can form back
tests so that might be a great tool I
don't know I don't really use it but
this is meant to be a real time trading
platform and quant opium for what I know
does not provide you with this to
contact and wants you to implement your
algorithms so they give you the backtest
tool and when your algorithm is working
you must execute it in their platform
with their code so they don't provide
you with the real-time trading platform
well I have an opinion on that maybe
it's because they want to get money from
yeah yeah it's normal of course but
that's the reason why this is different
or why we cannot use of course cuanto
tiempo days I just wanted to say that
that I liked this being open source
because those projects usually spend a
lot of time as closest and people is not
able to look at them or they don't go to
talks something like that so
congratulations okay thank you another
question around here so let's thank the
speaker again